[Music]
all right welcome to mastering the
middle game with me grandmaster been
fine gold as we party downstairs so
we're going to party like it's 1992 show
three games that I played in the early
1990s when I was a good player a long
time ago in a galaxy far far away
showing in theaters near you
so the first games my favorite because
of a comment my opponent made several
days later I won the game and it was
round 1 of a tournament in vikon's a was
the B group back then the B group wasn't
as strong as it is now so I was allowed
to play anyway I scored 50% in the
tournament and Turman was 11 rounds and
after round 7 or so I had like 50% and
my opponent was in clear first he
actually scored 8 out of his last 10 and
won the tournament at some point after
around 7 or 8 he said been after we
played in the first trend I thought you
were a good player so that the truth
hurts as we say okay so I was white this
is mastering the middle game so we'll
sort of skip the opening but it was like
a King's Indian Benoni hybrid and I get
this position with the Benelli also
because I play h3 against the benoni of
course black doesn't have to play C 5
these were the days when I played h3
against the King's Indian which I no
longer do I think
Conrade Holt is the main player who's
playing white in this position now okay
so c5 is a move and I've had this
position many times and I've also had
this position many times after C takes
d5 and I see to do well ok Rick and you
played Knight ft7 most of my opponents
play rook e8 check and then I play
Bishop e3 I'd never faced Knight ft7
before since and if you watch all of my
lectures I gave a lecture on chess the
21st century
and I showed a couple of games where in
King's Indians black was playing Knight
ft7 and then pushing all the funds on
the Kings side so well here Black's not
playing a5 since there's no e pawn black
and play f5 but actually the idea is
when black plays 95 if I take it my
opponent can take with the bishop
whereas if black plays the same plane
with the other night now when I take you
have to take with the pawn a small
difference also
this opens the line for the bishop and
it opens the diagonal for the Queen
which will both happen later
okay so 97 is a very unusual move and
it's the kind of move strong players
like to play and sort of secret prep
play a move that they know that you
don't and okay so I castled and I e5 and
he took with the pawn which is a little
surprising because you could you could
play the other 90 d7 and take with the
pawn and then I think actually it's
better if this Knight sign f6 because
then you could play 98 96 in such a
situation so not really a big fan of
Knight ft7 the main benefit for black is
black has to play f5 very quickly okay
and this is sort of the beginning of the
middle game I think the opening is over
now what the three middle games have in
common other than they were played in
the early 1990s is in all of the games I
had a lead in development and well if
you allow your opponent to catch up then
again P about equal so you try to punish
your opponent by playing aggressively
and opening up the position something I
don't you do now but I did when I was
younger
okay so I play f4 and I'd like to play
f5 index move and start an attack and
get control of the e4 square okay so my
point PI to f5 like sense Bishop h6 and
I like to tell my students and in all of
my lectures also that you should attempt
to move a different piece every move and
that was the same piece all the time so
my opponent moved
this night three times and traded it off
that move the bishop twice and
unfortunately these pieces haven't moved
because of that and I've moved almost
all of my pieces
okay the rooks attacked Queen d2 making
a battery and allowing my other rook to
get into the game Fischer d7 is an odd
move I think because it seems to me
black probably wants to get the knight
to f6 and then get the bishop out and I
mean the only square for the knight now
is a6 that doesn't seem too good so this
should be seven I think is a mistake
okay Bishop g5 attacking the Queen
trying to get rid of blacks only good
piece the bishop on e5 maybe we can
trade them but Queen b6 and rook e1 so
Bishop g5 force black into a reckoning
okay and since tomb stones one of my
favorite movies my opponent didn't have
much chance
so after Bishop g5 either my opponent's
Queen moves away from his King or they
trade the good bishop on e5 either ways
good 96 okay now I played a move that if
somebody else had played it I would say
I would play this move when I was good
so I must have been good at 1991 but not
now okay and the one piece that's
probably misplaced for white is the King
on g1 it's on a dark square which could
be attacked by his bishop on an open
diagonal and if I were to open up the
Kings side I'm going to push my King
side pawns so I play King h1 okay so I
was a good player that now I would
probably offer a draw okay Queen d6
rookie three preparing to double rooks
on the F or the e-file pending on how I
feel and well I didn't feel like
doubling on the e-file now if that was
my rook
so I rook have three and now we'll move
I would be really afraid to play now but
it actually makes sense because my
opponent's pieces over here aren't
really participating in the game my
pieces are all participating in the game
and if you cut the board in half you
know lengthwise you look to the right
left side of the board blacks King
doesn't have a lot of stuff near it and
black has pushed a lot of pawns in front
of his King and my rooks are on the F
file my Queen and Bishop make a battery
my bishops on d3 and it makes a lot of
sense I open up the Kings side and the
only thing that's really saving black is
this point on f5 if the pawn wasn't
there I could attack down the F file and
probably equally as important I could
play the move Knight e4 which would be
very strong not a lot of squares for the
black queen
so I played g4 which seems a little
crazy to me now but computers salaphi
guided by a new computer it got all wet
and well I'm threatening the f5 pawn
with a lot of things if you take on g4 I
could infiltrate which is what happened
and got a computer says I'm killing it
now according to my engine which I
didn't have run very long it says the
best move is Queen g3 which sacrifices
the bishop on d7 and actually after
Queen g3 rook takes d7 it plays h5 and
it says White's close to winning Black
has some tricks for the piece but okay
well Queen g3 is a computer move we're
not going to give our Bishop away so my
opponent played Bishop f5 which you know
makes the coordination between my rooks
sort of a block there and I take the
bishop and unfortunately for my opponent
taking the rook isn't very good because
I have Bishop e6 double check King g7
due to its legality there are no more
legal moves and then 94 and the truth
hurts
I could also play rook f7 check first 94
and a funny way to win the game
for example if Queen here I'm sure a lot
of moves win but probably this is what
the crowd would want Queen takes d4
Bishop f6 Rick g7 and irrespective
whether he goes dad fader g8 this is
still made this is a cuter man so
okay so taking on deaf sevens not
recommended my opponents are kind of
five
I played Bishop f4 which puts a little
skewer skewer action here
forcing Bishop e5 rook takes f5 and
again I have a materials equal my King
is safer than my opponents I have a past
D pawn that's protected and my opponents
light on c7 it makes you wonder why he
played Knight ft 795 in the opening if
his playing with his other night was
1986 to c7 and I probably said this in
previous lectures but you were probably
asleep
Gregory Caetano have told me many times
that in chess camps his kids are very
concerned with pawn structure but they
should be more concerned with peace
activity and pistols are worth more than
pawns if your pieces are active you
could never be a pawn structure while
you're checking your opponent okay he
has to trade all my pieces are attacking
his King 94 and queen g6 was plighted as
this flag was falling and of course he
realized that rook g5 wins his queen
probably when he played queen g6 he was
thinking rook takes g4 and he would get
both of my rooks but since my recon f4
is protected g5 just wins his queen
okay so after Queen g6 I'm not sure if
his flag fellow he resigned or both
something happened but okay here it
doesn't really matter because if you
move your queen to a safe square like d7
or da to b6 I'll play rook takes g4
check and Queen c3 check and you're not
going to be very happy
so this rook never moved and this Knight
moved twice to a terrible square whereas
my pieces were not only active they were
on very good squares so after that game
my opponent thought I was a good player
until he had more evidence to the
contrary
okay so that was Alfonso Ribeiro Holmes
and a nice guy he won the tournaments
and that was maybe the last tournament
he won okay so that was one of my better
games and I guess the the lecture is
over
I can get more games okay now my next
game is also nice because my opponents
name was if I be okay so he's from a
Scandinavian country because that's how
they roll
now I also play bridge and as the chess
players at home now and the huge
audience here and keep it down in the
back we have a huge audience here
there's a chess player named named a
guard a AGA Rd lot of A's of his name
but Umbridge is a much better name one
of the better British players in the
world his name is AAA and above one of
the A's there's a little circle okay if
you don't forget that circle so yeah
when you play chess that you play all
over the world you meet some interesting
characters this was played in cup a la
grande which is a really strong
tournament now in France and I was
living in Belgium at this time this was
in 1992 and they were just starting to
turn them and I think the first one was
maybe in the mid 80s and I played in
everyone between 88 92 this is pretty
strong term and now there's usually over
100 grandmasters guy was white and we
played a Queen's Gambit and we got the
symmetrical position and I like to play
a three here and the idea is if plaque
moves is Bishop then I can take the pawn
and then play b4 attacking the bishop
so my a3 actually makes some sense it's
hard to play a waiting move here I want
to game against me - the Romanian
Grandmaster which I should have lost he
played the move 94 interesting move get
my opponent traded now this is
transposed into some kind of pan off
Carroll Khan and he traded before I
moved my bishop so that's good I played
Bishop c4 in one move and now to me this
seems more like a Queens gambit accepted
because I play basically e3 Bishop takes
c4 and he's played c5 c takes d4 so
right now if I saw this position I would
think it was the Queen's game but
accepted it was actually like a boring
tarush where I play III and it could
also be a Carroll kind you get these
isolated queen pawn positions often okay
back in the day I actually had some
knowledge of stuff and I knew that in
this position after the move a six also
possible as b6r Bishop to d7
black wants to play b5 okay
and if black plays b5 and you can play
d5 you can take advantage of this open
diagonal but you really can't play d5
because your bishops hanging so the
correct move here I believe well I
believe the 1992 was Bishop a - now you
can't attack my Bishop I play Knight a5
or b5 and if you play b5 I'm ready to
play them of d5 taking advantage of
blacks pieces that haven't moved yet
plus the opening of the diagonal and
that's exactly what happened b5 d5 okay
so this is sort of forest and I'm
threatening to punish my opponent here
now if you trade Queens you're going to
lose material you've got a pin going on
here you have a threat and your knight
is defending your Bishop so you're going
to lose a piece and that's actually the
point of taking with a queen if I don't
take with a queen
I'm never winning a piece because Queens
defending the bishop so if we trade
Queens means up to find the bishop so
this should be seven another move Queen
h5 obviously I could never jump over my
knight so that was sort of a secure this
way to go to h5 now I have tremendous
pressure on the diagonal and on f7 and
h7 in such positions you would normally
see a knight on f6 then black would have
no issues with his Kings side since
there's no knight on f6
I might as well try to get my pieces
over there and right now my dish is
fantastic
my Queens well-placed I'm threatening to
put something on g5 and my rook is out
of the open line meanwhile his pieces
are sort of passive Queen d6 he wants to
come over and defend Bishop g5 he plays
the move rook g8 which loses a pawn
already I think black is a little worse
maybe more than a little worse and it's
a tough defensive job
since all of my pieces are attacking on
e7 and f7 and his Queens going to get
kicked for the move like rook a d1 he
prevents that activates his own rook and
now I have a very nice way to win a pawn
I trade and play the move 9 g5 very
simple chess I'm threatening f7 three
different ways and more importantly I'm
threatening me so what move would stop
all of this I assume you mean Queen g6
that's what you meant
so g6 doesn't stop Queen me but Queen g6
does okay now with Queen g6 the idea is
if I trade Queens he takes with a knight
nice safe I can't take his knight right
now because he takes my queen so he
thought this would save him but here I
have a very funny move that wins upon no
laughing at home do you see how I can
win upon here I'll give you a hint it's
a pawn capture good hint Bishop takes
pawn zip capture but that's not the
right one it's not bad it's probably the
least obvious Queen age 7 okay it's
check so that fors is that and now I'm
up upon a C's 5 is more than 4 yeah if
he takes my knight I take his knight
also his works hanging he plays rook e8
saving his work defending his Knight
I'll play Knight g5 and I'm a pawn up
and F sevens weak okay so that's what
happened and we traded so the middle
game is over I won upon and I won with
good technique which isn't really part
of this lecture but it was nice the way
I had all my pieces participating in the
attack of h7 and f7 my rook was on the e
line and probably b5 on his part was
slightly mistimed seems like d5 gives me
an advantage and the game extended very
quickly because I was able to win
another pawn when my opponent tried to
get counter play and the b5 pawn is
going away and I'll be down to pawns so
here he resigned pretty early
resignation I like that but the point
was the middle game where I got all my
pieces
I try to take advantage of my slight
leading development by playing d5 and
opening up the position for my pieces
okay and last but not least I moved back
to the u.s. in 1992 and I played
Michigan Senior Master Fred Lindsey
these are feeder ratings so they aren't
that indicative of the USCF rating and
this was played in a tournament we had
well when I was in Michigan now I don't
think they have anymore
it was the Michigan Invitational so we
would take the six best players in
Michigan we could find and we play
around Robin and there would be
appearance fees and prizes and I would
raise money and so forth and before and
after I was organizing it it was not
quite as strong and there weren't good
prizes and there worn appearance fees
and the playing site was outside
somewhere in the graveyard okay so this
is one of the nicer tournaments in
Michigan and Fred Lindsey doesn't play
very often but appearance fee and
everybody is good so okay now this was
one of my pet openings the Queen c2 name
is Osso I know a lot about it nice c6
doesn't move that I frequently face the
reason is you're attacking the D the d4
pawn and later you're preparing to play
the movie v and that's exactly what
happens and many years ago I learned
this idea of playing Bishop g5 and when
they attack your Bishop go back to d2
the reason is I want to Castle queenside
play for an opposite side attack and
when I play that moves g4 and h4 I want
my opponents who have played aged six so
I can gain a tempo here when he castles
King side he would prefer all his pawns
be unmoved
so I played Bishop g5 Bishop d2 many
times okay and I've had this position
before my plum played rook e8 usually
they play Queen e7 so when I play long
castle and they play e5 my rook and
their queen aren't lined up the Queen
gets off of the d8 square so Ricky it's
a little unusual by Castle queenside now
e5 is pretty dangerous because there's a
pin on the D file so Queen e7 seems like
black loss to tempo there h3 I want to
play g4
I used to play moves like g4 without
playing h3 sac my G pawn and get the
open G file but this was 1994 that 1991
so can older okay so H 3 e 5 D 5 and now
a move that may be confusing to you and
probably the reason why my opponent
played rook e8 before he played Queen e7
he didn't want to play quickie 7 because
it's very natural to play 97 here now
the night moves aren't very natural okay
but you do want to play the move Knight
c5 good square for the night so if your
night go to da I'm not sure where it's
going so you went to b8 and it's typical
for black to try to do something like
this if he doesn't want to activate his
knight he could go to f8 and defend his
King okay so Knight B it's not bad but
White has more space White has the two
bishops White has a lead in development
so we have to punish g4 9 h7 once again
black moves at PC already moved doesn't
want me to open the G file with g5 I
don't blame them ok again I like
developing my pieces I don't want to
play Bishop g2 because I want to use the
G file for my rook so I just played III
maybe e4 looks more natural to you but I
want to use this diagonal and in
particular the e4 square I like what my
knights on e4 that's often why I don't
put a pawn on e4 so piece can go there
h4 Bishop e2 g5 and then of course the
only move that keeps the King side
closed for black
keep it closed don't let me open up your
king close up the kingside Klaus you've
been age five right age five okay and
now the reason I play Bishop e2 instead
of the g2 now I attack the pawn again to
tempo and then why do I want to play
Bishop takes age 500 to play 94 and
since I have a dark square bishop and my
opponent does not I want to play f4 and
open this up for my bishop
okay so g6 is forced otherwise I take on
h5 and then 94 9 8 7
Rick g1 like c5 was played and after the
trade I play the crazy move
I think f4 is the most normal move yeah
my move is also normal but my moves
crazier so they're both crazy but f4 was
the idea but I had a very specific
reason why I played rook to g1 I didn't
do it to the defend by G pawn I did it
so I could push my Jeep on he's like you
can't push your Jeep on I did I didn't
go to that party to have any alcohol you
can't trick me
ya see I was younger then yeah now if
you don't take my bishop I just won your
H pawn and then I'll move my bishop way
and play h5 so ok now he saw Bishop h5
but he miscalculated as you can see this
game along with the other games my
opponents not necessarily moving all
their pieces and the ones that they do
move they move the many times that night
on h7 that's the night that was on c6
and then BA and then d7 and then f8 and
then yeah so my pieces all move once or
twice I get them an attacking position
and my opponent not not so much so
there's only one variation to calculate
he takes I play the obvious move
g6 yeah now it's tough I'm sort of
breaking through over there and even if
I don't win like oh no I'm down at peace
that's okay
I got a queen Shahrukh's a bishop
attacking his empty King I don't mind
being down a piece and you can never
find safe haven on h8 because I'll play
f4 and then that's not good
and you're ever going to find safe haven
on f8 because there's no Haven there I
got all kinds of tripling on the G file
Alekhine's gun fine bolts pistol this
was play to Detroit so we have a lot of
guns so you better watch it now he saw
Bishop h5 he saw g6 get it all worked
out gay he was planning on play Knight
f6 and I played double check so he has
to take with the king and I play queen
g6 and he has one legal move and he
thought okay Queen f7 doesn't work Queen
g7 doesn't work Queen GA doesn't work
Queen h7 doesn't work great now it turns
out I remember when the game ended and I
like turned on the computer that was
probably worse than me and I was
wondering what if I don't play the
winning move and it still thinks White's
winning if I just play like g5 and
double rooks and just attack f4 just
play some normal attacking move which
doesn't win by force it really likes
white because my attack just goes on
forever and as is well known many people
have lectured and said the same thing
yes serve our everybody alejandro well
you have opposite colored bishops the
attack usually works your opponent can't
really defend so even though if my
attack didn't work here by force which
does I'm still probably waiting anyway
so judgment wasn't very good on his part
I played rook g1 specifically a sack on
h5 and he let me do it and I'm crashing
through and again for the attack to be
successful it would be nice if you use
all of your pieces okay and so that's
what I'm doing and unfortunately for him
I move it ends the game immediately
which he didn't see there's three kinds
of moves you should see
sure's threats and what's the third kind
checks if your opponent puts you in
check and you're like oh no I didn't see
that then you're going to lose a lot of
games so what check did I play ending
the game Queen age six now my opponent
has two legal moves and they both allow
meet and one can play Queen g7 and I
play Queen g7 made if you could not play
Queen g7 and I also play Queen g7 mate
so it was a pulse full game I could
write if any Queen g7 mate so if king f7
Queen g7 million obviously rg7 also wins
or I could repeat Queen G sick so here
he obviously resigned you didn't see
Queen eh six not sure why it's the only
check that doesn't hang my queen so and
luckily if I didn't have Queen h6 f4 and
Rick g5 are very tough for black to
defend for a long period of time maybe
he could defend but still threatening
Queen h6 after both of those moves so I
doubt it so and again these pieces
didn't do a good job of this game
they stayed right there so if you want
to be successful in the middle game you
want to use all your pieces and you want
to take advantage when you've moved all
your pieces out your opponent's moving
around and around getting just the right
position but being a little too slow and
here my opponent's knight on f6 it's
amazing how many moves that made c6 be a
d7 f8 h 7f six too many moves okay and
while he's moving his knight six times
one two three four five six I got lucky
his rook and Bishop didn't move at all
my pieces all moved once or twice and I
got a big attack on his king my king was
very safe and when I Castle opposite
sides which I've said in many lectures I
like what I'm attacking and they're not
I'll give a pawn oh I'll give a piece
away there's no attack on my king that's
how you win a chess and people forget
that they forget that's how you win is
you checkmate your opponent they're like
oh I have the e4 square and I have a
bind and I have an extra pawn I have a
passed pawn
you win by checkmating your opponent and
none of that stuff matters if you
checkmate your opponent so when I
sacrifice
apiece if my opponent's pieces haven't
moved yet if I have an attack if I don't
see a defense for my opponent that's
what I'm going to do mate is mate
[Music]